none other than the actress Pam Grier
right here on the Rich Eisen show you
don't Pam I am doing so well
thank you for the invitation we're
coming here because I'm I just loved
sports
I was raised I was lucky to come from an
environment of rural military and urban
so I got the best of all worlds you got
the Air Force Academy and then just
flying over and they have basketball
football we even play flag every
Thanksgiving and back home in Colorado I
freeze my Corral so we have an ice rink
and we play ghetto hockey people versus
the dogs and everyone brings their
potluck and they bring and we play with
a broom or dust mop the sneakers and the
dogs
everyone's dogs are like 20 30 dogs with
with tennis balls and we have to get the
tennis ball hit it into the net before a
dog gets it and runs up through the
corral they got the dogs beat is three
years in a row yeah well I could imagine
that the dog can really get something
you can meet you lose but it's so much
fun
great neighborhood who we respond to
each other's cultures very well yeah I
mean ghetto hockey is that Oh ha okay
they call me Mommy G so might well be my
hockey well I mean it's interesting you
you you like hockey well Pam you've
lived in you've been living your best
life and you're now in this film blessed
in this TV show bless this mess on on
ABC 16 yes starting April 16th we'll
definitely talk about that in a second
but you are just telling Chris that's
Chris my buddy Chris across the way over
there you were just telling us before hi
Chris you were just saying before we
started that who did you who did you
have over to the house that you said
when they come Darryl Jones was playing
bass for the Rolling Stones and he came
over once to the ranch they all get lost
and think they're gonna die because it's
a two lane country road and then I had
Snoop Dogg exhibit and Trey they had a
concert and Fiddler's Green yeah and I
invited him over to have breakfast my
mom was early 80s at the time and before
they went on the show and made sure that
a barbeque guy delivered food to them
and I try to you know
take care of folks when they come to
town and so they came out had breakfast
they had like you know nine hundred eggs
you know fifty pounds of bacon toast you
see everything and Linda's loved it they
wanted to see my horses okay which I
rescued for it they're pretty writing
program these will be a horse as these
are jumpers he's a Grand Prix jumpers
they're not tiny you know sport horse so
snoop city's going you know he want to
ride him he wanted here an exhibit who
is half his size said I'll do it you
know so it's always that the mini
diminutive he rode takes charge yeah but
my horses were acting up they came down
sliding and jumping and booking a skate
everybody I said and so I said no I
don't want to get snoop heard he's got a
concert so you know stay back everybody
was fun they came out we did did snoop
have gin with his juice no he did not
but he has something else before
breakfast because when they opened my
mom and I were standing I see I bought a
small one level brick ranch house right
and so my barn is bigger than my house
so we standing out there and they CP
we're looking for he we're looking for
and they drive right by Mary said turn
around come back so they came up to the
drive and said we thought it was the
helps house oh no it's a small house you
know cuz that really like a house like
warren buffett's you know small brick
house you know very unpretentious you
can fix it up on the inside and so they
drove in it parked in all the whole crew
12 members can't got out of the van they
opened the door smoke billowed out and
hit my mom in the face she said oh
that's spicy they proceeded to have the
munchies and so did my mom I was like
serving and cooking for an hour oh my
goodness so anyway no it wasn't any gin
and juice Pam Grier here on the Rich
Eisen show who's the most I guess
talented athlete you've ever met we can
worked with or came across or anything
like that well through the 50 years of
my career early early on early on was
bird named Lewis Alcindor jr. who became
Kareem abdul-jabbar who was my first
boyfriend when I transferred from
Colorado to try to get into UCLA film
school
and I'm telling you there was I he
looked at me at a club world the
Commodores are hanging out in Crenshaw
and he had a cane in glasses and and I
was this Wallflower with the one skirt
and one blouse and and he came up to me
and he saw this fish catfish out of
water and he he said where you from
because I look quite different that
looked like a homely country girl
Colorado by Wyoming hmm and he had that
look and whisky we skate you know I've
been skiing since I was a little kid
riding horses and stuff so he was the
first and then I had met Rosie Greer
later at my second job at KHOW radio he
was promoting I think Daniel Boone at
the time and he came through and they
said you're Greer you related and I said
he doesn't look like it you know we
don't have the nose so I don't know you
can we can use it if you want to but I
don't think you don't come to my house
with your size because my mom would say
he just out of house on home please
don't invite him to the house so those
are the second and then the late
Florence Joyner hmm flo-jo how'd you
meet her she came to see me in a play
called Frankie and Johnny that clair de
lune in San Diego she and her husband
and it was so great to see her just
stunning and her her nails and her hair
and she wanted to just show an imagery a
that women could still be beautiful and
have nails in here and they still
haven't broken their her record she was
outstanding and brilliant and smart and
she came to see me there was no envy or
anything like that it was so uplifting
cuz I ran track as well in high school I
ran the dashes high jumped hurdles
I Bowl those in the bowling like
anything to keep from doing the dishes I
was doing sports ok said it all worked
out it worked out clearly and then I met
Earvin Magic Johnson when he'd opened up
his theater so I've I've been able to
meet a future you've worked
Jim Brown correct oh no I did the
original og Fred Williamson and they
very fantastic athletes and actually I
met Jim early and I didn't know who he
was I was visiting some friends in the
Hollywood Hills area um 6:17 1971 okay I
was trying to get you know four or five
jobs so I could stay and go to UCLA and
I said oh look at this Hill I could go
hiking mm-hmm no one hikes up Sunset
Plaza Drive right but me with a fur vest
on and a hiking stick in my $9.99 ears
hiking boots I started hiking up the the
drive right and Jim Brown in a a
Mercedes convertible with Fred with a
bevy of beauties hanging out all over
we're driving up Sunset Plaza and they
saw me hiking and said what is she do is
that right who is that country ass woman
walking up hiking up Sunset Plaza Drive
and so they looked at me and they said I
think that's rosey Grier's cousin yeah
just because you had the same last yeah
but I don't know where they'd seen me
because I was not known the first week I
was there I did get to back up sing with
Bobby Womack and then he said I have a
friend who needs some more singers so
his name is Sylvester Stewart and since
she sing gospel and you play keyboards
you play instruments you know it's a
double triple scale $300 a week oh my
gosh I drove out to to California with
$33 and a bucket of chicken you know so
you know $300 is like whoo I the next
day went to CBS records and walked in up
the elevator and them in the I guess
he's not the manager but something with
the session mm-hmm and he came to me he
said okay sign in you'll be getting
triple scaled have you ever worked with
wonder love Stevie Wonder's wonder
laughs hmm it was Minnie Riperton
Cerreta right Denise Williams and I was
seeing all these fabulous singers I've
heard and I'm like no what I get to if
you don't kick me out because I'm at
really stupid right now sure he says
well coming in and meeting meet
Sylvester and I walked through where the
glass window is to the studio hmm
Sly and the Family Stone there's this
afro his fist fringe
he's got the bass this is amazing and
Buddy Mouse's playing drums in the
background I I just froze I imagine I
just hear hear I really was off the
sugar beet truck
did you ever had your last one for you
did you ever come across Ali do you ever
meet Muhammad Ali yes I did yeah at a
benefit and unfortunately he was quite
ill at the time and they had always
invited me to go on trips and things
like that but I'm not one to do them not
really some of that goes out after nine
o'clock sure I'm kind of a conservative
person because of things that have
happened to me in my life sure I kind of
watch myself got it yeah well now you're
on bless this mess on ABC that premieres
Tuesday April 16th Lake Bell and Dax
Shepard play they play a young
disheartened couple newly Wed they leave
the bright lights big city of New York
to go back to the heartland where we all
find our heart okay and they're gonna go
back because I believe in the heartland
where I live in Colorado the farmers are
the hero of the day and without the
farmers there's no food and for them to
come back and just jump in mmm head
first feet first but first thinking they
can be farmers overnight and they think
they can do it alone until they meet our
motley crew I'm the sheriff the theatre
director I know everybody's secrets I
know who's creepin who's doing what I've
taken drunk people home my bourbon
babies and they meet me and at Begley Jr
and he plays Rudy Dax Shepard plays Mike
and Lake Bell plays real they are the
most talented energetic actors they
make what could be silly so rich and
humorous everyday things that you just
watch them it's just joy I work with
them and I guess I brought some funny to
them because when I met Lake you know
their thing well they said Pam lives the
life you know she's she's in dirt she
loves animals she's this is what she
does and they clean her up to do movies
and so I didn't know how they would
portray these wonderful people in the
heartland you know not only in New
Mexico and Nebraska and Kansas and Idaho
Wyoming my mom's from Wyoming I know
these folks and they don't curse
I don't curse around children
I don't curse I would say kakadu to
pee-pee but I won't use any other you
know anything that will offend them and
I came that morning right from the farm
jumped in the limo took off my Spanx so
you know I'd have a badonkadonk going
and I had smelled like the farm and I
walked into Fox Studios and I smelled
the part and that's how I got it and Pam
Grier you're here on the show talking
about it bless this mess wonderful and
may Blessed messenger Tuesday April 16th
9:30 p.m. Eastern time on ABC we're
about to see a clip for the television
only segment great to see you here thank
you for coming on this show thank you
for having loved you obviously Jackie
Brown and Tarantino and then the entire
filmography my goodness 57 years you
just compress good to see you for coming
to Colorado you have to do my show well
I would love it are you kidding me yeah
I do this since I hear it's such a party
my guys will do from the barn fantastic
at Pam Grier on Twitter we'll check out
a clip when we come back here Chris
Brockman's news update on the other side
Big Ben listen to me did he not it seems
like big mistake I don't know as Daxi
was from Michigan okay so I kind of
support my bro know Pam Grier here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience